ich habe meine gute laune heute morgen
acht anstatt nur vier minuten ziehen
lassen also heute ist alles so richtig
und mit diesen unfassbar gut geklauten
tweet meine lieben freunde darf ich euch
ganz ganz herzlich begrüßen die heute zu
einem neuen video auf meinem kanal und
zwar sieht es bereits im titel
eingeblendet ich her gehe heute mit euch
auf die dümmsten tweets aller zeiten die
ich gefunden habe
und das hier ist der erste tweet da geht
es nämlich darum dass ein kollege sagt
denkst du eigentlich zu hause auch an
die arbeit und den personen die den
tweet verpasst hat antwortet einfach ich
denke nicht mal auf arbeit an die arbeit
so ging es mir bei meinen praktiker ist
auch immer das ist der nächste schritt
und zwar twitter dort eine frau ich habe
zwei freikarten für erwachsene für den
kölner zoo zu verschenken bei interesse
bitte die m macht euch einen schönen tag
und dann fügt sie noch an nach so sind
29 siebtklässler dabei das stört doch
nicht oder
[Applaus]
ich werde auf jeden fall noch ein
bisschen öfter klatschen durch mein
zimmer laufen allerdings würde ich sagen
machen jetzt erstmal weiter mit dem
nächsten tweet und zwar ist es das hier
ich auf arbeit und dann ein angehängtes
foto von einem hohen status anwesenheit
simulator auf solche ideen also so was
einerseits zu entwickeln aber auf der
anderen seite dass man auf die idee
kommen diesen tweet raushauen das
gleiche frage ich nicht auch bei diesem
tweet den ihr hier gerade schon wieder
eingeblendet und zwar ist die
überschrift flirten kann nicht und dann
ein angehängtes foto mit dem chat
verlauf einer anderen person die schreib
ich suche nette leute wie du sie
antwortet wie dich und er antwortet
genau erzählt was und dann schreibt sie
wusstest du dass der hahn auf der
kellogg's packung cornelius heiß ich
wusste es nicht wusstet ihr dass
schreibt wir gerne in den kommentaren
juckt mich eigentlich aber auch
eigentlichen feuchten kurz habe beim
bettwäsche wechseln ein geldstück
gefunden das muss mir wohl beim letzten
sex aus der tasche gefallen sein oder
ein foto mit einem 10 pfennig cent stück
hat ist ja gehörig lange herbei dir mein
lieber beim nächsten speed hat jemand
die ard tagesschau geschaut und hat dort
einfach die twitter überschrift drüber
gepackt harry potter und das und dann
auch schon aus der tagesschau gutachten
der fünf weisen wie kommt man auf so
eine scheiße also die leute müssen ja
wirklich das sehen im fernsehen und
müssen sich denken oh gutachten der fünf
weisen dass wir jetzt lustig wenn ich
davon screenshot nehme und da harry
potter und das und das twittern würde
also seid ihr da für kreative prozesse
hpc gestoßen
remember entree aus die unendliche
geschichte
das ist im outfield sondern ein foto von
atrium und ja
ich werde komplett
wieder die unendliche geschichte habt
ihr das geguckt der film ist viel älter
als da wo ich geboren bin glaube ich
aber meine mutter hat uns doch früher
vorgesetzten das war echt sieht auch mit
fuhr diesem fliegenden drachen und so
mega schön cool freut mich genau erst
mal anständig luft auf die kette und
dann ab ins grüne und dann ein foto wie
eine frau durch den reifen sondern die
felge beziehungsweise die kette oder die
speicher oder was auch immer da aus dem
fell genug um ein fan verraten hat
ja mein ziel für 2015 meine ziele zu
erfüllen die für 2014 geplant waren
welche ich 2013 machen wollte weil ich
es mit 2012 vorgenommen habe ja das ist
kein lustiger tweet sondern die wahrheit
in meinem fall beim nächsten tweet hat
eine person einfach ein foto genommen
von zwei piloten und hat ihm einen
piloten eine augenklappe gemalt und dann
drüber geschrieben zwei fliegen mit
einer klappe also zwei leute fliegen mit
einer klappe das ist alles nicht
verstanden hab ich ja noch mal kurz
erklären diese person hat einen tattoo
laden entdeckt der hakuna matata heißt
egal das ist eine unfassbare krasse
namens kombi
ich mache jetzt ein tattoo geschäft aus
dass der nächste schnee nicht ausgesucht
habe und zwar wird er getwittert von der
userin jude war sah wie sie hat nämlich
dazu geschrieben was viele deutsche aber
eigentlich meinen wenn sie sagen sie
sind auf der straße aufgewachsen dieser
teppich und ich glaube jedes kind hatte
diesen teppich also ich weiß nicht wie
es bei euch war meiner war ein bisschen
anders jetzt wo ich das gerade mal so
vergleiche also meiner war viel viel
kleiner
also doch nicht so dass da irgendwie
eine kreuzung war sondern ganz viele
kleine sachen das war normal geil oder
so mit hot wheels kleinen autos drüber
phase
datenschutz ist doch gar nicht so schwer
twittert der user dann gerhausen und
dann ein foto von einem simply 16gb usb
2.0 speicherstick und da steht einfach
mit abdeckkappe für hohen datenschutz ja
also das der wahnsinn ich kann deine
daten kommen wollen dahinter die
bestimmt und eine kleine kappe daran
sorry aber wer denkt sich denn
unternehmen die das dazu schreiben und
was denkt sich ein unternehmen wenn sie
das hier als
man muss irgendwo sagen das ist auch
sehr einfallsreich ist aber ich meine du
kannst die konstruktion so klein machen
mit dem tesa stattdessen machen die so
war es und es nimmt einfach so viel
platz weg aber es sieht cool aus dass
man den lassen im nächsten schritt frage
ich mich ob das ganze wirklich
absichtlich vor dem plakat ihrer so
gemacht wurde oder ob das alles wirklich
reiner zufall war
weil links war dieses plakat die mega
tournee dieter bohlen und rechts das
plakat warum gott das alles zulässt im
wiener ballhaus und die beiden sachen
nebeneinander als halt ja also ich
feiere dem plakat ihre auf jeden fall
auch das hier ist der nächste schritt
und zwar schreibt der user mit dem namen
der gashahn man muss so aufpassen und
dann darunter ein foto von einer
steckdose über der drüber steht kein
trinkwasser
da muss ganz ehrlich sagen mir fällt
jetzt auf anhieb kein beispiel einer bar
in deutschland ist es so häufig dass da
einfach irgendwas ist wenn man weiß man
soll das nicht machen aber dass wir
trotzdem noch ein schild so irgendwie
auf einem hochhaus steht dann bitte
nicht runter springen oder so so hey ja
okay das war das vielleicht ein blödes
beispiel oder wenn in einer therme dann
einfach steht bitte nicht unter wasser
rauchen oder irgendwie sowas also das
war ein blödes beispiel das habe ich
jetzt auch noch nie gesehen euch dass
ihr wisst was ich meine deutschland ist
einfach so ein land die wollen überall
schilder hin klatschen egal ob's was
bringt oder nicht der deutsche staat
denkt ich auch werden zu viel
steuergelder mein gott dann schneller
und stellte das ist luca alles klar
ich habe drei asse gerade getrunken und
ich bin komplett koffein in himmel rein
also sorry falls ich ein bisschen
überdreht allerdings war direkt weiter
mit dem nächsten
meine lieben freunde und zwar dass
dieser hier vom tatsächlich auswärtigen
amt deutschland gepostet wir gehen jetzt
in einem irischen pub und betrinken uns
ab morgen arbeiten wir dann wieder für
ein besseres europa versprochen
ja das ist schön zu lesen wenn die
vertreter seines landes sich dann mal
schön betrinken und das dann auch noch
öffentlich posten das hier ist
allerdings direkt der nächste schritt
den ich raus und habe und zwar ist die
überschrift deutsche adventskalender und
eine dhl packstation
ich weiß nicht ob ich der einzige bin
aber ich selbst habe noch nie ein paket
von einer dhl packstation abgeholt muss
man dafür da irgendwie registriert seien
angemeldet weil realtech ich weiß nicht
wie es bei euch ist wenn man irgendwo
auf dem land lebt oder in irgendeinem
dorf oder keine ahnung wo da kennt man
dann wahrscheinlich den dhl boot und er
ist mega korrekt und bringt dann auch
gerne mal die pakete vorbei bei köln das
letzte mal dass ich im paket wirklich
hier in meinem ein stockwerk gebracht
bekommen hat war gefühlt 1830 ich muss
die pakete immer irgendwo am dom abholen
einer anderen rheinseite irgendwo in
brasilien also ich hab keine ahnung dhl
falls ihr das hier gerade seht was ihr
euch dabei denkt aber das ist damit der
person also ich meine gleichzeitigen wir
verstehen ja mal kein bock gegen die
hoch zu laufen also okay es sind zwei
stockwerke vor allem dann mit einem
kleinen paket aber oder letztens also
ich will das ist jetzt auch überhaupt
kein vorwurf an dhl ich werde ich kann
die paketboten wir verstehen die fabrik
man das zu einem paketshop und der
empfänger muss es dann irgendwie abholen
was natürlich für mich dann ein bisschen
blöd dass wir da hinfahren muss uns
weiter und so fort aber ist natürlich
schon stress wenn man die ganze zeit
rumlaufen muss was ich allerdings wird
führen ist ich hab letztens apps
beispielsweise 15 euro versand auf
italien bezahlt und die haben einfach
drei mal gesagt sie haben den eingang
nicht gefunden bis ich dann gesagt habe
komme ich wohl das paket bei euch ab
timo zehn kilometer ausserhalb der zahlt
sie schon 15 euro versand first world
problems oh mein gott ich habe so viel
koffein intro sie tut mir leid dass ich
so viel redet allerdings ist das in der
nächste schritt und zwar steht dort kopf
sagt vergisst sie das herz sagt ruft sie
an und der alkohol sagt nimm diese
baustellen beleuchtung mit und du wirst
dich besser fühlen und das habe ich noch
nie gemacht kind zwei will unbedingt bei
mcdonald's bestellen ich flüstere ihm
die richtigen worte ins ohr er lautstark
20 schnickschnack jetzt mit bbq sauce
ich glaube die person wollte 20 chicken
mcnuggets mit barbecue soße
aber nah dran bei so was muss ich mich
immer an activity erinnern das ist so
ein spiel wo man unter anderem halt auch
wörter umschreiben muss und meine
schwester er hatte dort das das wort
gezogen bärenhöhle
sie hat allerdings nicht bärenhöhle
gelesen sondern bärenhöhle und hat dann
eine hölle gemalt in der die bären drin
sind
das hier ist allerdings schon der
drittletzte trittin draußen sind habe
und zwar tag 12 sie haben mich noch
immer nicht entdeckt und die könnte man
die kommentare schreiben
was ihr denkt was an diesem bild falsch
sein könnte
keine ahnung machen wir allerdings
direkt weiter mit dem nächsten schritt
und zwar dass dieser hier deutsches
pesto dann ein bild von dem hehler curry
gewürz ketchup delikat und ich bin ganz
ehrlich ich liebe diesen ketchup
übertrieben es gibt leute die sagen dass
er hat voll blöd mit dem gewürz drin und
so will ich glaube bei dem ketchup gibt
es nur entweder man liebt ihn oder man
hasst ihn und das hier ist auch
überhaupt nicht bezahlt also keine
werbung oder irgendwas aber ich liebe
diesen ketchup hela curry gewürz ketchup
job gesehen wollen wir allerdings nun
jetzt auch schon zum letzten tweet für
das heutige video und zwar dass wieder
etwas mit einem wundervollen freund der
deutschen post zu tun und zwar ist
dieser tweet hier herr müller ihr scheiß
paket ist da bitte betrachten wir seit
zugestellt ja herr müller herr müller ob
sie wird der herr müller hallo die
unterschrift sondern ja die dass das ich
wünschte die würden mal so zu mir kommen
nein
[Musik]